memories
yeah sorry for the bumpy start yeah we
are online I had um probably broadcasted
some of the advertising videos and stuff
but I'm glad that we're actually online
um they had the kind of the trailer
before the broadcast started because I
wanted to check if we're really online
yeah the complicated thing is which I
wasn't able to really tell in the chat
because it's just a little bit too
trickiest that the ICC accounting
for streaming it's not just used by one
guy not just by me but also by the other
guys doing live shows and this is not a
typical password it's um a different um
technical device that is used but let's
get going and played some chess
okie dokie you'll see the remains of a
bullet game that I played to warm up now
um I'm just sitting there for 30 minutes
I don't know what what good it did but
I'm going to start here with some five
minute action
let's see another thing that I maybe
will do we're going to see about that
maybe I will play um a couple of um
fun fun bullet games
let's see
okay I'm going for five minutes here
against the blitzking
I hope that the video
um and I mean the whole window
Arrangement is fine it was a bit um a
bit um
screwed up after the um simul that I did
on Friday it completely um yeah
uh yeah it didn't it made my whole desk
very untidy
okay so here black was able to get in D7
to D5
interesting
yeah so Queen 2b3 is the way to trying
to punish this
this possible weakness there on D5 and
end on B7
so Queen B3 is the way to go
let's see what he's doing D5 and B7 is
hanging that's the only way to try to
punish to punish that
let's see
um
yes yes that's exactly the idea someone
writes that John Bartholomew used on ICC
to play bullet maybe I'm going to ask
him for a couple of bullet games he's a
much better bullet player so I'll
probably get my my
butt-handed to me I think is an
expression that sometimes used but um
we're going to try for that I'm going to
ask John after this game if he's up for
for this
I guess he is and he's his heavy
favorite in this match
if we if we do it okay I can take A7 but
this looks really greedy
to taking two pawns but on the other
hand I don't see why not
it's my queen tripped I don't see it
just grabbing the two pawns here
um
they are not intending to play an hour
of bullet but maybe briefly
um I'm not quite sure what's going on
here
am I disconnected or something no he is
disconnected maybe he is let's check
no
look wasn't running I was kind of
irritating
but um it um it is it seems to be okay
now okay
um Bishop to B4 I'm not quite sure what
this is doing
okay once you get in maybe a knight G4
and maybe trying to trap McQueen again
but I don't see how I don't see how
really
Rook A8 as soil Queen B7
I'm definitely ready to return one Pawn
if he's getting too much pressure
okay
okay I'm going to Castle
Rook Rook A8 I still have Queen B7
and I also have the idea Queen A6 to D3
yeah I don't really see his compensation
for two points he probably has some
compensation for one Pawn but I'm not
sure about two
let's see Queen A6 right
trying to
get back to D3
yeah Queen to D3
I really I'm I'm up the whole Queen side
which is quite a lot but what he always
can do is take on C3 and demolish my
Pawn structure a little bit
yeah I mean this is this is always an
argument why is he giving me the bishop
um yeah he just uh he just gave up by uh
by simply uh disconnecting yeah I can't
just take the bishop but he preferred to
disconnect okay I'm going for another
five minute game
yeah this is a bit um a bit of a
discussion about the bullet chess uh I
have a very clear opinion about it
bullet chess is something that you can
play once in a while for
for let's say 20 minutes or so and then
it's okay I don't really like to do it
um in any any more than that sometimes I
feel like oh let's just just play some
quick fun game and don't care so much
about the quality and then it's okay but
it's not uh something to be to be done
um like for hours yeah some of my
students sometimes ask me should I play
bullet and I say well you shouldn't but
yeah we all do once in a while and if
you don't overdo it I don't see a big
problem with that
so
why not once in a while it's it's
certainly okay
let's see
um yeah I got a queen's Indian and he's
playing my opponent she missed the
series is playing um slowish setup here
with
Bishop to F4 I wonder if C5 is a movie
or is D5 a reply or C5 looks normal
looks kind of normal
okay
ah I think this is probably probably the
point of the whole thing right
this thing okay Queen to F3 funny
how do I play here yeah my Bishop so
kind of a kind of unlucky spot here
okay
I want to try to get the Knight to C7
and try to regroup
nights if I go to d7s maybe
I'm sorry trying to prepare B5
my problem in this position is that the
bishop on B7 is a totally ridiculous
piece
um yeah Blitz Blitz chess uh that's
after I've gave my opinion about bullet
he has a question about the blitz yeah I
think Blitz is um something that um can
be used um it it still
it's close to decent chests sometimes
and it can be it can be used to practice
things especially you can practice your
your openings and and um or let's say
you can practice the middle games that
come from your openings quite good in
Blitz
if you um
if you have some decent opposition you
will be able to to check if you really
know your stuff and know how to play
things especially if you have opponents
that are on your skill level
um no I don't agree Mercury Blitz and
bullet is is not the same thing five
minutes is entirely different to one
minute where where you really really
really have to pre-move and and be super
quick to stand any kind of chance and
then um and then Blitz it's um
it's um it's simply more time available
um yeah the Queen's engine Indian is
somewhat less popular nowadays but it's
not because it's um it's in any problem
or so it's just that other openings or
other lines
um have gotten somewhat more exposure
recently but there is no theoretical
problem at all with the Queen's Indian
okay I was thinking that I can go here
but he might take D6 I'm not quite sure
but I don't really have an alternative
here
I'm attacking D2
K so he plays it
in a in a more simple fashion
okay so we went to deform
hmm yes C6 and F5 so I'm going to try to
regroup him he can go Knight C6 but
not sure how bad this really is I want
to cover all this
yeah the Knight on C7 certainly can be
improved
I wonder how okay he wants to try to
play F4 hmm okay so maybe here F4 Knight
G6
he might have E5 but
here I'm also attacking D4 so after F4
there's maybe Knight D3
available I can still play Knight D3 but
let's do this try to prevent a form
trying to prevent F4 if my knight on C7
would be better
and not just completely off it would be
probably quite okay for me this position
at least playable
okay I'm going to push him
trying to make some use of my pieces
here the Knight might come to B5
that's not so clear where his Knight is
going actually this is interesting
Knight B1 B3 is a trap of the bishop and
takes takes well where are you going
Knight A2 B3 yes yes2 has to fire yeah
there is no way with no way to play
with the standard moves okay so if I'm
taking he's going to do what Knight E4 I
have to check on B6
I did not plan that but I have it
it's kind of fun
yeah we have a benoni structure the
benoni is full of
little orc with tricks
awkward for wide I mean
okay
so I can take that
yeah why not why not actually on Knight
F4 that's also an interesting move let's
do that
I still have the queen B6 idea
and I can take D5 possibly
wow very irritating for white all this
check
so I can take D5 if I like but Knight F4
very very tricky business
three I can also take them
or Bishop F5 I like Bishop F5 somehow
getting my Bishop out from D7
hmm
yeah I thought Knight E6 is good but
then Knight F6 is hitting me hmm
okay
I overlooked that move that Knight F6 is
now threatened I really overlooked
um awkward
okay then I have to jump in now
not much I can do
down to 118
okay time to
time to really focus hard here it will
be
that will be very tricky now
maybe I'm okay yeah maybe I'm okay
I can take E2 now probably
and Rook d8 just trying to get the pawn
hmm
yeah if I take there is this possible
kind of it's it's all a bit uh Bitcoin
should then coincidental but I think
it's working
somehow somehow things keep
things are still okay
um what is this
um and then he has got the check okay
okay let's go here I just took me too
much time
I gotta yeah I got a winning end game
now this is fun
threatening G6
and let's um bring the oops corn bring
the king up
so maybe stop his King
there for the moment and then
promote stuff
yeah just blocking things and I will
I will promote the Pawns
I hope
um
uh my time
my time
yeah um the thing is that I have a ton
of Pawns here
going with the King all the way to C1
I'm not sure that this was the best
technical play ever but I think it was
enough
yep okay I will I will do that in nine
seconds I really will
yeah that was a weird weird game
that was a weird game yeah there is no
increment in the in the pool but um
um it's okay five zero is okay I need to
go for for more five zero games I did
not play any um
any um any games today
um
I'm looking for questions are there any
questions
um
there's a question here I have a problem
with my Pawn movement to take push or
keep tension do you have some general
advice on that matter
um not to really
not really
um it all depends on the the concrete
position what is right in general
however if you look at the majority of
games it's um
it's um more often you see people
um people um giving up on the attention
too early they trade too much and they
they play two simplistics very often
it's better to um to keep more
more tension on them on the board
but chess is a very concrete game and it
depends very much on the particular
position
okay we have um
gaming against fighting dragon
some German flag let's see if I know
this guy let's see
Christian yeah that's an I am from
Germany um
but uh no player I know
I mean like in person I know the name
but uh
never met him or played him okay he
played um delayed capture on C6 this is
interesting it's kind of similar to what
cards are sometimes played this delayed
capture on C6
in the Berlin
not sure how this relates um but
I'm just going to do normal things
going for the fian Chateau here to to
improve the bishop a little bit maybe on
a very good day I'll manage F5 okay that
has to be a very good day but uh
it might work
I never really understood
very much what the point of this capture
is on C6 in this kind of situation of
course the pawn structure is somewhat
um yeah Black's Pawn structure somewhat
um
shaken but it's not um it doesn't feel
like a huge issue I'm aware that um
Carlson's in Carlson's case from the
Berlin it's a somewhat different
position
but um
still it feels uh in this in this case I
don't really
I don't really get it to be honest
let's see what am I doing here I can't
flake Queen here always like that
disturbing move G3 Queen H3
and I also might have Bishop to H6
yeah let's go Bishop H6 and ask him
about this Pawn on G4
hmm white can go Knight to D5 maybe
threatening Knight F6 check
um this question what do I think about
table bases should you learn this stuff
no
I mean table bases are form for
reference purposes it can be an idea to
um to use some table bases
form for learning theoretical end games
or let's say practicing learning is
wrong practicing them for example if you
want to look at rook and pawn against
them against a single Rook
um where the table base is playing
absolutely perfectly
um there it does make make some sense to
maybe play against the computer
um what is this guy doing here
um okay he can't take on D5 I understand
yeah or Bishop H6 it both comes into
consideration
um
yeah I can take C1 this was my original
intention
yeah let's do that it's probably
simple and not so bad
Rook E4 might come okay let's put this
here
not not totally sure what I should do I
can play for F5
I'm going out of a possible Tempo here
with G3 and playing Rook f8 F5 is an
idea my A6 Pawn is kind of on its own
yeah a mask for
um I'm asked for an example of a bluff
and chest
um I'm not sure if there's something
like a bluff and chest there is this
thing but it's not so easy to put put a
concrete example out I can give you one
one example actually
um some time ago it's um it's maybe like
three or four years ago I was playing in
the in the Belgium league and um in the
Belgium League you um you have a hard
time to protect to predict I'm sorry
um to predict your opponent you know you
play a certain team but you you really
can tell who you're playing and it
happened that I arrived at the place and
it turned out that I have to head to
play a grand master
um a Grandmaster
um
I'm not going to tell you the name
um it was a Grandmaster about 2500
rating and it is funny
um he played um in um in the in the
opposing team obviously and uh he's he
was a teammate in my Dutch team so it
was funny that um that I actually knew
him a little bit and I was um I knew
that he's an E4 player of course and he
played E4 but I knew that normally he's
not um that he plays that he plays the
Italian game or the scotch opening he
does not play the Rulo pass and then we
started our game and he played the rule
Lopez and I was thinking okay why is he
playing the real Lopez what is the idea
behind that if he's never playing it and
I was thinking okay what can I do now I
could play my usual stuff yeah I like it
she gorin but at the time I looked a
little bit at the the schliemann Gambit
the yanish Gambit with three F5 and I
had this I had this hunch that he was
playing the rui just to play against one
of my slowish lines so I played the
schliemann and I did not really know
much about it but I sort of yeah it was
a bluff in a way because I thought okay
he's an expert on some other opening and
um he won't know the schliemann in such
detail and it turned out I was right he
um
of course you knew something but I had
no problem out of the opening I actually
had a very nice position and
um so this Bluff kind of worked out I
don't know what would have happened if I
played a slow Edge line
um this way I got a decent position and
this surprise worked but um it was kind
of a bluff if if for some reason he
um yeah let's say he had without me
knowing he had some detailed knowledge
about the opening the schliemann Gambit
I might maybe I would have been in
trouble I don't know it was a kind of a
bluff
this is maybe a little example of a
bluff and chest
but it's not happening that often
um I'm wondering if I'm playing this
right here and probably not
I'm playing this kind of weird
um hmm
C5
maybe I'm still okay here but uh
while I'm telling this story
foreign
was telling the story I played this this
end game I'm not sure if I played it
well
I don't want King E4 to happen so
maybe maybe I can push the
the H Pawn
I can go to C7 it's not going to work
huh I'm not sure if she fought this win
um but what else what else I can go
hmm I cannot really move the Pawns
I mean I can play King E6 D7 whatever
okay I'm pushing here I have to have to
play a move at some point
I was thinking Rook D6 you can actually
play Rook H6 that was it was a bit a bit
stupid
you know that's probably going to end in
a draw
here's Rook H6 yeah yeah
hmm
okay I can I can try this
and keep this Pawn for the moment but he
has King E4 yes
exactly
um
it's a draw what can you do
it's just a draw
um what did I do here
that's kind of unnecessary
why did I get into this end game
ah okay
yeah it's still a draw of course but uh
that was really unnecessary
I only have six seconds here
and that sucks
yeah I played this so terribly
ah come on how idiotic was that from a
better end game to lose
wow
wow now I relax too early then and
thinking it's just to draw
oh
yeah losing is a kind of a kind of sick
here
well okay let's get to the next game
uh uh okay this is a high rated guy DL 2
5 20.
see what he's going to do gotta put the
groin thought okay
yeah Bishop B6 that's an interesting
line one of the better lines in this in
this variation
let's see what he's going to play Bishop
C8 there's even a move yes
yeah he knows his his theory here
okay Bishop B2 and black is going for E5
that's Bishop B6 move is quite good
let's see yeah I think I'm going to to
take on E5 twice
this line is um is very decent for black
has very very good equal lighting
chances here okay so I'm going Queen D4
I guess
I can cover the pawn here with B4
yeah okay this this game it was a was a
was an example by increment just makes
some sense that's true but um yeah
maybe as you see is going to introduce
an increment pool after all
of course I I should never lose the the
game anyhow
it was purely purely my own my own
thought there
okay so we have this this end game here
which is about equal I guess
black maybe has Knight E6 to play um
to play um
to take the form
okay I'm going to
try to trade on the e-file
a minor piece end game is quite okay for
me
this
I would also like to trade my D3 Bishop
against the Knight
but I'm not going to be able to probably
okay maybe B5 is this a move
Maybe
the problem is that he might take and
play Rook A3
which is kind of awkward
okay I'm going to try that it's a bit a
bit a bit tricky
I think I'm going to get this back
oh yeah interesting move
so I'm taking Bishop takes
okay
very interesting move
here and then I have a form and Rook be
there still have Rook B3 even so it's
not a problem or anything it's not a
deadly pin or something like that
let's do this right A4 I can't even take
I think if I'm not wrong
okay and here Bishop A4 was my idea
takes Rook takes should be about equal
and it's about equal this position
yeah Knight C3
I can take there or Bishop D5 you know
Bishop D5 is
is the normal move
it seems to be just equal
um yeah taking doesn't make much sense I
can
approach here I'm going to offer a draw
maybe he takes it
it's really not much going on here
okay he's continuing
um if I'm going to E3 yes Knight C2
check
that might be one idea that he's still
entertaining I can go back here
on 95
cannot trap the Knight unfortunately I
would like to play for for a night strap
down but it's not going to work
Jim
trying to fix some of his pawns on light
squares
maybe here I don't know it's just
nothing going on
um I intended to give this check but
it's it's a kind of a stupid idea
just have to settle for this
okay it's going for King D5 maybe yeah
it's still nothing going on I think
okay let's push
um yeah three three minutes and two
second increment is just a far better
time control than five zero and people
who argue otherwise um I don't take very
much seriously
it just increases the quality of the
games so much that there's no argument
really
the only argument is maybe for for
spectators five zero is quite uh quite
spectacular but the quality of the games
is just far far better with increment
okay cheeks
going to T King E3 I think it's just a
draw round
I wonder if I go here
I really there's no no winning idea
uh check I can check them
he's got a form
F4 King D3 King D5 A4 it's a move
and
F4 I'm going A4
he has to go King E5 I think I just said
wrong
this is just a draw
don't see any way for him to do
something here
yeah and and draw
yeah I think it's it's it's okay result
not not to do
oops ah no I unfortunately clicked on 15
minutes
um okay I'm trying to trying to to abort
that
it's really too long
ah they agreed to a draw gifting gifting
some points okay so I just right click
click the wrong button
um
um yeah the quality of the game in three
plus two is higher because uh the games
are actually played out to the end and
this means that also there are sometimes
situation in 5-0 or other non-increment
time controls where one side knows it's
he's going to win on time and then they
are not really um they don't need to
prove anything anymore they can play any
any crap to be quite Frank and
um this is simply not uh possible in
increment time controls they have to
play well until the end of the game and
sometimes you really notice that people
are well they don't even want to play
chess anymore if they see okay I'm going
to win on time they just play play
nonsensical moves all the time and this
is not going to happen in an increment
time control okay I'm going to try to
just win the G4 Pawn here I know it's
kind of a funny looking idea but I'm
attacking this pawn and I don't see how
is going to um going to protect it
he cannot play the F Pawn because of the
A7 Bishop
it's a kind of funny this opening
I don't have anything to drink here
yeah 10 minute game is uh is okay yeah
it's uh it's just longer
but you will still encounter this uh
this uh this this weird situation at the
end
yeah it's it's simply I mean especially
if you have the technical equipment to
play with an increment it's always
preferable for terms of quality of the
games just just just like that
um the only is the other thing that is
quite interesting actually but this is
kind of uncommon in international chess
is this concept of a delay that is
sometimes used in you in American
tournaments where they don't they don't
accumulate the time but they get like a
certain number of seconds per move that
is not accumulated this is also I think
a very interesting idea because people
sometimes um
argue with some kind of justification
that with increment you um you can just
Shuffle around sometimes to gain time on
the clock and use the time later
yeah and um sometimes this leads to kind
of nonsensical shuffling just to gain
time this is not um not happening with
the delay as well
so um
this makes um some sense as well
yeah I'm going with my knight
trying to get to my night to
G6 I'm hoping
to succeed in this in this task
uh why didn't I play G4 G4 for the for
the piece
I can give the check I can give the
check
still I should have considered that
okay I'm going for Rook F7 trying to be
quick here
okay so preventing D5
yeah the delay concept is not in not not
bad I think I like it actually
and um in the tournament chess I think
um there are there are various um time
controls of course oh wait um still D5
takes takes Knight takes Knight default
check
King is seven hmm
that's kind of funky
I can start with G4 though
it's not ideal
but I can go here right
this is my I just want to trade one Rook
don't want any more anything more
yeah actually I'm going to D7
yeah so he tries to keep the Rook on the
seventh probably with success
huh so what am I doing now I have to
check yeah
okay he doesn't have a clear way to
activate maybe I can actually move the
king and then take the Knight take the
pawn on D5
could be could be an interesting way to
play I want to isolate this Pawn so that
C4 is not possible
yes so F5 I guess
preventing Knight to E4
if I go back to d8 he might play a C5
hmm
I don't know
Mercury what is this thing within a 3-2
game can do thousand moves and I can
only do 40. if you can only play 40
moves in a game with two second
increment you have a serious problem
it's not about Nakamura it's about you
with a two second increment you can make
an infinite number of moves and not just
40.
even with the one second increment you
can do a hell of a lot of moves
and the important thing is um
you can also
draw the draw end games and win the
simple one end games
this is the the most important thing
about it
okay going E4
or not
I can give this check let's give this a
check
see okay if I do if I go E4
probably Knight E5 and I cannot take D6
I mean I can't just take the six
probably I should
I just took the pony and I'm and I'm one
minute up on the clock
it's kind of good news
so let's see I can give this check
and then Rook F1 Maybe
it's got Knight F7 and and the captcha
this is this is a bit awkward
I wonder I can go G4
Rook F7 now
yeah maybe do it like that I'm not not
totally sure here
about the best technical way to play
Knight G5 if I take them it's it's
awkward but I can attack F2 and um and
B2 my my Rook is now the more active
piece this is what I'm hoping for
that I can get both the F Pawn and the B
Pawn
he's letting the clock run down quite
quite a bit
okay
he's going for
Knight C7 and Knight C5 probably
um can give the trick here
keep stuff for the moment
um
begin a check or I can take B2 Knight C7
Knight C7 I have Knight C5
can cover
and then you can check A6
a bit awkward
okay
I didn't see that move that's not good
now for what Knight E6
I have King D5 though
that's two pawns okay
yeah okay going to win that one
that was that was tricky yeah I'm going
to stream Force for a while I mean we
had a we had a um
a bit of a late start so
I'm going to um going to play let's say
like that I'm going to play a couple of
more Blitz Games but um we might go for
some something quick later
maybe maybe I can ask um ask um John
before me if he's he's up for some one
plus one this is a fun time control that
I totally like one
um one minute and one second increment
so it's not very often played but it's
uh this is the kind of bullet that I
really like
don't try
I'm going to negotiate um
to play
but um he's he's idling a bit maybe some
busy with something else but I'm going
to try
my keyboard
um I've got um
mechanical Cherry keyboard
I know it's kind of noisy but I like it
um yeah John's not answering me maybe
he's busy it's possible but I put out a
message to him so maybe we get to see
him see a match
okay
I'm going to play another five minute
game
okay
yeah I'm doing okay tonight scoring I
mean about 50 against my reading peers
what are my thoughts on multicast I
don't know it's uh obviously a very very
strong player but um he plays um kind of
funky funky openings and some funny
ideas sometimes
um it's hard to tell I mean there are
those rumors that this Magnus cars maybe
it is
um yeah it's always fun to speculate if
you uh I mean I've been on the ICC since
1998 which is quite a while like 17
years it sounds like an eternity and
there have been those uh guys coming and
going rumor rumor to who who it is and
there's Anonymous accounts that are
super strong and that was about guesses
and so on you never know who who is who
is who I think there's also
or there are definitely some accounts
that are shared you know like there is a
there's a couple of players playing on
the account
okay so I have a
um a royal passes black can exchange
with
with a funny line here that uh that I
that I sometimes play
it is um kind of unusual but
um I think quite okay for for black
I got a I got a request to play a
sicilian Dragon
um yeah
I have absolutely no knowledge about the
dragon it's difficult for me to to play
okay but I'm glad about this year I have
the two Bishops for no particular
compensation
and um
night
it is um quite okay now already I think
what he played wasn't very critical
so I have the two Bishops and white
doesn't have much to show for it maybe
Knight G5 now trying to get rid of one
Bishop no he didn't do that
let's see how am I going to play I'm
going to play F6 G5 maybe or
how am I going to do this of course
um white is still quite okay
white is still quite okay oh sorry A6 is
hanging
I have to attend to that so
put it back where F7 Maybe
yeah account sharing is actually um
prohibited on the ICC but it still
happens
I mean I never did that but it happens
that some players share accounts
question do you think positional players
are less affected by age than tactical
players
um there's someone saying um that he
feels that at 34
um his tactics are not what they used to
be yeah but this is kind of normal
you you simply um with with age you you
tend to make more tactical mistake it's
um mistakes it's just normal
I'm I'm 40 and um I know that I
definitely were a bit fresher when I was
in my 20s or so
also physical fitness helps quite a lot
not just a matter of age I mean you can
if you are very physically fit person
you certainly um Can compensate for
things yeah I know that all this
um moving back looks weird but what I'm
doing here I'm preserving my two Bishops
for later
so
and I'm going to try to get yet another
Bishop
um what is he doing here I don't get it
I want to go to E6 I see
uh yeah
hmm
don't want to treat
I mean okay maybe I could have taken but
trying to to say that the pawn on C5 is
weak
Maybe
okay
I'm going back
again is moving there hmm
I want to cover E6 how do I do that I
can play Rook D6
looks a bit awkward but I don't want
Knight E6
okay I'm going to push the Knight back
Knight A6 King B7 is a Night Trap so he
has to go back
and now how am I going to play
I don't quite know how to develop
here maybe I can go Rook to D5 actually
intending A5 that's an interesting idea
I like that very much
my Bishops are used on the initial
squares this is very neat
I like that
and they overlook this move
unfortunately
hmm
wow okay
I wonder do I have some more active move
than just dropping back
Rook F5 Maybe
but that's kind of that's kind of weird
it's a weird move
um again I overlooked a simple move oh
ah what am I doing here come on it was
just a nice this was such a nice
position
I really was a lot better with my two
Bishops and now I have to give up
stupid material here
ah what a shame
what is shame I totally
totally screwed this up
I don't know why he's giving me the this
this here and he's giving me the
exchange
wow
okay that's a weird turn of events
yes this looks active but
really this is so great
I'm going to push now
let's push Pawns
what a weird game
so what am I going to do here Bishop B8
Rook here
that's awkward
yeah yes some attacking ideas here with
the Rook on A3
okay I probably have to do that
for okay and
awkward
but necessary I guess
what is this this is equal material
right after all this blundering
funny
okay
I can okay I can attack here on
B5 and trade B against D Pawn
this should actually quite good for
black
I mean not like winning or so but quite
nice
my king is is active it's more active
than his King
can try to
go up here
yeah it's probably it wrong
it's probably a draw
any way to trying to play for a win here
no probably not that was
what
why is he going back
strange
why would you go back
huh
okay
I'm trying to win this game which is
kind of funny but I'm trying
it's just that the Knight is somewhat
tricky yeah
okay I'm going to try to run to the
Pawns
if he trades um he's in zuk's one
okay so he can just stay now
unless I'm taking the night
okay
that game that game was really really
bad it was really really bad
but okay you have to have to uh
have to uh Windows those those wins
those um those games as well
it took me a while to see that the night
was really up for grabs
wow okay
okay I'm having a good good score here
yeah we are on for about an hour now but
um
we'll continue a little bit
this uh this late start was really
awkward
yeah I didn't see that as well he should
have gone to A4 or something and then
it's really questionable what I did
I actually should have taken on G5 maybe
right it still is it raw
okay do I get get a new game here
a new five minute game
no I'm trying to contact John
Bartholomew but he's idling so he's
still locked on the ISSC but maybe doing
something it happens to me all the time
I log on then I know I'm off cooking
which could actually be the case at um
where he's at it's um
it's um about about dinner time
yeah one plus one is a funny time
control this is actually something that
I like to play
it's super quick but you still manage to
play some decent uh games once in a
while
you know I once um I went I played um
this quite a bit
some some years ago I was really funny
that in two Con in in one week
I had a
um bishop and Knight mates two times
once I was mating with the one second
increment
and the other time I was mated both
times
the maid was performed successfully okay
I'm playing Abdul kadia from Azerbaijan
at least it's an azerbaijani flag
and we have a somewhat rare liner in the
sloth with Queen B3
and um
enter Queen B6 I'm trying to get
B4 B5 in quickly yes he's fighting that
with
this move okay I'm going for Bishop F4
this is good anyway I guess getting this
bishop out maybe here black can try
something like F6
always taking that's surprising
okay yeah I can move the Rook now I'm
threatening B5 here which she ignores
why isn't this good okay
I can utilize this pinning situation
I'm kind of surprised
that he allowed that
it's um a well-known favorable
transformation I'm threatening Knight E5
and and all kinds of awkward things okay
if I'm taking now
Knight E5 check King E8 back
I cannot play Rook B1 because of
but I can prepare that okay the
alternative is to play Bishop a form
and just stay stay there for Knight E5
uh this may be um F6 interesting
I think I'm I'm okay if I just take
and then play G4
I want to play Rook B1 at the end and um
I don't I don't see how he defends
against that really
Rook B1 at the end on the B Pawn
will be difficult like Bishop G6 I take
Rook B1 and he cannot defend the B Pawn
it looks um it looks quite strong
if he goes F6 I take F5 Fe Bishop takes
and again I'm threatening that
it looks that looks kind of kind of
problematic
Bishop E4 F3 it it doesn't look good
I was really surprised that he allowed
B5 in this position here after E3 I
expected Rook C8 to prevent this
but um didn't happen
um yeah I sometimes I do sometimes
resign positions yeah if they feel like
if they are completely lost and
I felt um I think if they if they um
if I think in in this position if I have
what did he do oh he resigned okay yeah
B7 is gone
um in a situation where I think that the
opponent is um
is um it would win easily with an
increment I mean easily with an
increment I would resign bishop and
Knight made I would not resign
because simple up to Grand Masters
people fail with that
but like Queen up or so I would resign
and it also sometimes I mean I try to
don't really have to care about it
because of the increment
um okay opponent wants to abort the game
don't know why exactly but I don't mind
okay let's see if I get new game
and also depends a little bit on on how
the game went yeah I mean
if I'm I'm like
if I'm like winning completely the whole
game or so and then then I make a
mistake and I'm I'm about to win on time
I probably just take the time when I
don't know it's a very difficult
situation it's much simpler
it's just much simpler if you give
people an increment because then it is
um it is just due to It's Just Pure
Chess skill it's not about any kind of
etiquette it just played out to the end
yeah increment is uh it's just promoting
playing chess and not hitting the clock
or making any any funny Mouse statistics
okay playing Black against draw hardship
I got in I got a request to play the
dragon okay I I would have played the
dragon but uh okay instead I get the the
um the Smith Mora Gambit
okay I'm going to
play in a in a very very classical
fashion here
this setup that was recently recommended
by
umson in one of his
video series
and um yeah I like that it's it's a it's
a simple
it's a simple
um setup
white definitely has some
has an um a compensation
but uh it's it's totally playable for
black as well I'm going to take
yeah people are making fun in the chat
of
former women world champion
um
um because she failed with the bishop
and knight checkmate
um yeah I understand it is kind of
embarrassing that this happened but
um I don't know the thing is
you can make fun of that but the the
problem is simply that even with the
increment there are still human beings
playing and
um if you you are nervous and you're you
have to
yeah everybody is watching you and so on
there it's very very strange things
happening in this case you know under
those circumstances and
um yeah I'm not really
I don't really like to make a fun out of
people because
um they they fail with those kind of
things it um it is it is difficult
sometimes to to to to to to to yeah to
to have the presence of mind after four
or five hours of play I know that I've
done my fair share of totally ridiculous
stuff after
um after after a long game
um has been played so
um I'm not going to ridicule people
there I've made my fair share of stupid
stuff
I mean not exactly this end game which
is
fairly easy but um
it's um it happens it simply happens
okay so he's going for this this
compensation there I think I have to
take that finally
it um it looks kind of dangerous now
I'm attacking b283
it looks like a good counter play
yeah I mean for example
um recently I played a game in the Dutch
League where um the computer afterwards
gave me an advantage of Plus 14. plus
14. I wasn't a queen up but it the
advantage that I could get with a fairly
simple move was really really big and
after four or four and a half hours I
simply couldn't bring up any kind of
concentration and played uh played
really badly at the end I only managed
to get a draw and it was um
it was a very simple actually
I even saw the winning idea but I simply
couldn't calculate after those five
hours I don't know what it was it's not
like I'm too stupid to win it's just uh
kind of um kind of strange what
sometimes happens
yeah while we were chatting I think I
have a very good position here
um and I think I can actually take on B2
here
because I'm threatening Queen H2 and I'm
threatening the rook and he's in the pin
I think this is kind of winning I hope
um yeah so how am I actually winning
um I can give this check here and take
H4 maybe this is
a way to do it
Knight H2 mate
um mate
Fork Fork yeah and I'm I'm kind of I
don't know a ton of Pawns up
how much three pawns that's it's quite
good
let's see okay going to check again
hmm
can check here but what is it leading to
does it lead to anything
maybe just go back here
for D5 also and the queen coming over
Queen A2 would blunder the queen that's
not a good idea
hmm I don't know maybe I'm playing this
in a bit of a too relaxed fashion here
how do I actually win Rook C8 for Queen
C2 made
that's a good move Queen C2 checkmate
threatening threatening make mate is
often a good idea
five yes
Bishop D5 Queen C2 made Pawn takes E4
wins the queen
that should win it
that does Win It
yeah you should never
um you should never underestimate um
what what's happening in a in a longer
in a long game right it's simple it's
simply uh fatigue and nerves that that
kick in and
um yeah there have been so many weird
things happening
Let's uh do this for example in a in a
in a
in a team in a team match recently we
had a situation where it was even after
seven boards were finished it was an
even score there was just one game going
and there were two International Masters
playing and the one international Master
he he's he wanted to avoid the draw
and he um he managed to avoid the draw
but he just ran into a Checkmate in one
move just a one move checkmate and this
is something that would never happen to
him if um it was at the beginning of the
game yeah not at the end of the game it
was just uh fatigue kicking in and um
yeah it um it's just a different
situation than than at the at the start
okay going for
one or two more games this is late start
I guess you deserve some kind of
compensation
I'm playing quite well here gaining
gaining points
I mean I'm not sure if I'm playing well
but at least I'm playing um successfully
okay I'm requesting a new game
yes there's a famous uh game um Arnold
with white against Ivan shook where Evan
shook could mate in one move but uh did
not see it he simply was
he he was having um
I don't know brain brain slip or however
you may call it he simply did not see
the maiden one
yeah I'm requesting a game but don't get
one
probably not not that much
going on in this in the on the server
right now I can play a three minute game
for a change okay I got a three minute
game
maybe we um get um
get a game that way okay this is three
minute chess against Gambit Destroyer
let's see what he's coming up with we
have a main line classical
okay
hmm I did not know that this is a line
actually
this bishop A6 or maybe 1975 is kind of
yeah that might be a might be an idea
black is quite well developed here
with the
future
capture on D4 yeah spending yet another
move with the queen yeah which is not
ideal
but um I did not see what else to do
yeah three minute is um is a bit um
is a bit quick for my taste when it
comes to in commentary I'm not hopeless
at this time I'm playing don't play it
often but um it is um for commentary
it's um it's a bit quick
okay Knight to F6 hmm
okay I'm going to cover E2 here
trying to get
my development somehow completed maybe
Knight E3 to come yeah he's very nicely
developed here he's got uh this is his
compensation for the bishop pair
that I have
I'm not threatening Bishop B5 Knight D5
Queen D5 winning a piece
so yeah he's um
doing something against it
okay
so I'm going here attacking his Bishop
this bishop doesn't have a clear way to
go
where is he going with this piece
that's funny I don't know I don't know
where this is going to go
it just drops the bishop it's funny
right
it just uh it's just funny
okay I'm going trying to get another
five minute game going
yeah I didn't even see that this bishop
was trapped on the um
only saw it uh after I played Queen A4
he basically killed himself there
came trying maybe another three minute
game kind of strange that I don't don't
get a five minute gamer uh the thing I
think there is a a bit of action going
on in the in the one middle pool
actually
wow I don't get a game in the three
minute and the five minute pool what is
this this is unheard of
it's kind of funny okay what time is it
it's uh 15 minutes uh to to midnight
um I did not read all the books in the
back and I mean
there's more
it's quite it's it's quite
it's quite nice
um I don't get a game I simply don't get
a game I can try to ask no I got a three
minute game now okay maybe we may play
before for a change
um I didn't open Sicilian I think I'm
going to stop at at midnight yeah this
is all chess books
I also had um I had a ton of non-chess
books of course but I sold almost all of
it
trying to um yeah trying to get some
space let's say and uh
yeah I mean they are just collecting do
it over the years
and dust dot is the wrong word dust
um so what I'm going to do here I've got
an open Sicilian not my
usual kind of opening
but let's see can I go G4 let's do G4 G5
it's the only kind of plan that I know
in the society
so let's get going
okay 97 is still fairly solid here right
hmm
I don't really have an attack here I
think
it looks I don't know
I'm not very familiar with E4 position
so it's always or not always but
sometimes a bit of a struggle for me
before maybe he has B4
yeah before looks kind of good
I doesn't do it
B4 Knight E4 maybe yeah here at least I
have an idea like Bishop E5 Knight E4
Knight F6
hmm no I did not then I did not expect
but probably not bad
just a text my bishop and he's attacking
H4
yeah I don't know it doesn't look good
to to trade with the
playing against the bishop pair but um I
didn't see an alternative
I already gave away ton tons of my chess
books to my chess club so no giveaway
planned in the near future
um yeah there's a question
um about the popularity of one D4
compared to one e form yes it's
definitely the case that at the moment
D4 is um gaining in popularity in top
level chess and yeah with very good
reason the
um especially E4 E5 and especially the
Berlin defense in the Roy Lopez and the
the martial attack they are both holding
um up excellently well
so um white is um sometimes as Peter
swidlack sometimes has a quite quite
finally one D4 it's the ultimate anti
Berlin and yeah this is really the case
it's not um so much that the top level
GMS believe that D4 is much better or
anything it's just that they don't
really see
um much that they can do
against those two problem openings the
Marshall and and the Berlin
and I'm kind of surprised that he took
on C5
this can only be better for me now at
least a little bit with the pawn
it's easier to draw with 1d4 someone
writes now that exact that's exactly
wrong it's much easier to draw with one
E4
when one E4 has has many uh has some
many more forced drawing lines and D4
not so much
in a situation where you desperately
need a draw
um it's really the better choice to play
to play E4
okay so let's see what's going going to
happen here
trying to win the pawn there the B Pawn
I'm not sure what he's doing okay
I can pressurize
the H7 Pawn here
okay prepare not prepare prevent Rook A4
and then taking the H Pawn
right looks nice
okay
let's push it push it down the board
oh I didn't even see that
huh
hmm
okay let's take
how do you prevent the
promotion now
I don't don't think you can right
okay
yeah it's still it's not not really
difficult but it's still some moves that
I need to play to promote the F Pawn so
he's continuing
all right okay It ultimately didn't take
that long
hmm
yep so I got him at the end
okay so I'm going to wrap it up after
the after the next um
next game just going going for one more
game and then it's mid light okay
playing scotlander
um Grand Master here with an U.S flag
but he's not playing and now he is
playing
1d4 yeah let's see I'm going to play my
usual nimzo
okay
we're going to get a sharp position here
ah I keep forgetting this line
all right let's see
Knight Knight C7 on 97 I always
forgetting that
but okay we're going to see
um what is my favorite book of my my
chess books that sets difficult to tell
there are many many uh good books around
um what I very much like is a is a book
that is um
it's not containing much chess actually
but it is still
um great great fun to to read it's um
the collection of janhein Donna's
articles called the king it's a it's a
great book about Chess
and Donna was quite a character
um and I'm also quite relaxed here with
a three minute time control I'm spending
tons of time this is probably a mistake
actually
but um
I'm I'm kind of
trouble to remember to remember this
line
um okay I have to take now probably
and go here I wonder if he can sacrifice
on H7
something like that there's this whole
what I played is very very dangerous for
black
Rook comes to D6 yeah yeah I remember
that this is very dangerous but
I had to play a move ultimately
yeah if I take Knight G5 is coming
and then he's got the check yeah okay
I'm not going to survive this probably
it's got Knight G5 and all kinds of
things happening
now now that that opening uh is not
really very forgiving if you make a
mistake
it is quite a good line actually
but um it as mentioned you cannot afford
any any inaccurate moves I actually have
no no square for the queen
okay I can't go to C8 but he's going to
make me Queen H4 Knight G5
and then I've got rookie five okay
yeah
uh Queen H7
yeah okay I'm going to allow him to play
that out
yeah look that's quite quite funny I can
I can yeah Rook F7 is also made okay I'm
going to resign
now I played that nicely
um I screwed up this opening this is a
line that I have um
examined but I could not remember the
precise movesets it's difficult when you
are in a three minute game situation
okay I'm going to wrap it up now I don't
not going to start a new game we were
online about one and a half hours
finally I think it was just fair to
stream a little bit longer after the
very um yeah very delayed start of the
broadcast yeah I hope you like the games
I think it was was good fun maybe uh
next time we can arrange for some some
one plus one bullet action but uh wasn't
happening tonight okay hope you enjoyed
it I'm back next week thanks for
watching